many videos ago we first looked at the
idea of representing a periodic function
as a set of weighted cosines and sines
as a sum as the infinite sum of weighted
cosines and sines and then we did some
work in order to
get some basics in terms of some of
these integrals which we then started to
use to derive formulas for the various
coefficients and we are almost there we
have figured out a formula for a sub 0
we figured out a coefficient in general
for any of the coefficients on the
cosines and now let's figure out a way
to figure out the coefficients on the
signs
so how can we do that
well we're going to use a very similar
technique that we did to figure out the
formula for a sub n
what we're going to do
is multiply
both sides of this equation right over
here by sine of n t so let's do that
so sine
of n t
and so if we multiply the right hand
side by sine of n t that means we're
going to multiply every one of the
infinite terms by sine of n t
so sine
of n t
sine
of n t i think you well this is always a
little time consuming but i'll get there
sine of n t
sine of n
t
sine
of n t
sine of n t and of course there's these
dot dot dots so we're just showing in
general we're taking each of the each of
these terms and multiplying by sine of
nt we'll do it for all of the terms
we're going to keep on doing this on and
on forever for an infinite number of
terms
well now let's take the integral of both
sides of this equation the definite
integral from 0 to 2 pi and once again
i'm picking that interval because 2 pi
is the period of the periodic function
that we care about and everything else
that i've been doing has been over that
interval of 2 pi so i'll just keep
focusing it on that
so from 0 to 2 pi dt
and i could say the integral of this
whole thing but we know that the
integral of a sum of a bunch of things
is also the same thing as the sum of the
integrals and we also know that we could
take these
these constant multipliers of
expressions outside of integrals and so
this is going to be equal to if i take
the integral of the right hand side the
definite integral is going to be from 0
to 2 pi
dt
0 to 2 pi
to 2 pi
dt we're almost there 0 to 2 pi
dt
to 2 pi
dt and 0 to 2 pi
dt and i would be doing this for every
term in this fourier in this fourier
expansion now this is where some of that
integration work is going to be valuable
we've already shown that sine of the the
definite integral from zero to two pi of
sine of nt dt is going to be equal to
zero for n being
any integer so we saw that
we saw that right over there so
that tells us that that term is going to
be 0 so that's going to be equal to 0
and we also know that when we take a
cosine of something times t times the
sine of something times t where these
are integers and you take that definite
integral we know that's going to be zero
so all of those are going to be a zero
and we also know that when you take the
sine of two different non two different
coefficients right over or sine of some
integer coefficient times t times sine
of some other integer coefficient times
t that these are also going to be equal
to zero
we saw that
we saw that right over here that is this
property and so really all you're left
with the only one that does not become 0
is this term right over here
where it's sine of nt times sine of nt
and what is that going to be equal to
well this inside of the integral that's
the same thing let me do this in a
different color since i'm using orange
to cross out everything that ends up
becoming 0.
so that is the same thing as the
definite integral from 0 to 2 pi of sine
squared
of nt dt and i'll do the or the dt is
still there so i'm just replacing the
blue stuff with the sine squared of nt
and we know what that's going to be
we know that when the coefficient on the
t is a non-zero integer that this is
going to result in pi
so we know
that
all of this stuff right over here let me
do that in a different color
all of
we know that all of this stuff is going
to evaluate
or actually maybe all of this stuff is
going to become pi so we know that b sub
n times pi is going to be equal to this
definite integral or we could write let
me write it this way b
sub n
times pi is equal to
because everything else ends up becoming
0 is going to be equal to 0 the definite
integral from 0 to 2 pi i'll put my dt
out here
of f of t
f of t
times sine of nt
sine
of n
t
dt and so we could then divide both
sides by
divide both sides by pi and we get a
little bit of a drum roll we get b sub n
actually i could write that i'll write
that in that same blue color we get b
sub n
i'll do it actually right here
b sub n is going to be equal to
1 over pi
times the definite integral from 0 to 2
pi 0 to 2 pi
remember dt here you have your f of t
here and then you have your sine
sine
n t
so once again that was pretty
straightforward now that we knew these
these these properties of integral so we
knew how to evaluate these integrals
that are
definite integrals where we're taking of
cosine or sine or products of cosines
and sines and using these three formulas
we can now attempt to to find the
fourier expansion the fourier series
find the coefficients for our square
wave